[Music]
what's up everyone and welcome back to
the final week of the br gridiron
punishment league your champions of it
all flemlow and jack this week's losers
are amanda and lou lou you look upset
i'm a little hurt about my team you
played to win the game you guys won
congrats to you guys appreciate it who
let you down this week besides the low
actually lou came in third place no
you didn't you came in laughed every
time i got punished
and amanda selected their punishment
they will be completing the cinnamon
challenge i love cinnamon but i've never
tried the challenge i can already see
the cinnamon filling up lou's screen i
might have to back up here this is the
final punishment amanda you like to
start the punishment yourself donate it
to lou ladies first i think we should do
it together i'm a little scared right
now i'm gonna be 100 with you that's why
you want to help me lou this is the case
man i've never seen y'all so nervous
before a challenge right i'm actually
shaking this is high stakes all right
lou let's do it to an incredible season
distinctive football three two
one
swallow
he got it lou got to go with a bigger
scoop
oh here we go
cinnamon clouds it looks like lou might
have bodied got the salines in it come
on man this
[Applause]
look at amanda she's going through it
they fell apart in crisis man lou did
you even blow any cinnamon out i just
coughed a little bit but we all good i
just blew cinnamon all over this hotel
let's talk about our favorite moments
from this incredible season flemlow you
were the least punished but what was
your favorite punishment of it all i'm
gonna go with with lou with the leader
door open remix man come on man do you
still remember any of the lyrics y'all
gonna have to get open
you're gonna have to get up
amanda what was your favorite it's
probably the chicken wings because even
though there were footballs tipped to my
hand i love chicken wings my favorite i
like the hot dogs but i liked going
through the eggs with flem low we had a
good partnership they were doing us
dirty and we we got through that the
pumpkin was the worst that was
disgusting yeah i forgot about that well
when you get punished like five or six
out of the eight weeks though i guess
it's tough to remember them all to me i
consider those trophies one two three
four five unbelievable season with you
all hopefully we get to do it again
sometime soon signing off for one final
time i'm jack that's amanda that's lou
that's flemlow and this was the br
gridiron punishment league
[Music]